the decade that began with the tea party
and is ending with historic victories
for conservative priorities from the
legislature to the culture to the
federal courts is now coming to a close
we will examine how history will look
back on the past ten years then a man
gets sixteen years behind bars for
burning a gay pride flag Christianity
today endorses the impeachment and
removal of President Trump and we clear
up some fake news on Christmas all that
and more on Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
there is so much to get to today it is
not just the end of a year that we're
coming up on it is the end of a decade
and I think that our perception of this
decade is very very different than what
we can actually conclude from what
happened on the political front we'll
get to that in a second first I got to
thank our friends over at Express VPN
you know how important it is to protect
your data I've been telling you this
forever now people are trying to get
your data The Daily wire we we invest
thousands of dollars in cyber security
because we regularly get these kinds of
attacks but guess what individuals get
those attacks every day too and you
can't afford to have your own IT
department you're protecting you that's
why you need to Express VPN I know that
if you are listening to this show you
got some weird stuff going on in your
browser history all right you probably
go to some of those sites that you don't
want your employer to know you've been
on you know I'm talking about daily wire
calm stuff like that that's why you've
got to encrypt and anonymize your data
okay when you don't use Express VPN it
is like leaving the door unlocked
to your house and especially leaving the
door unlocked when you've got all sorts
of valuables your financial records
everything you've been looking at people
can get it so one of the easiest ways to
secure your internet data is expressvpn
you just click one button on your
computer or your smartphone and you're
protected I know what you're thinking
you just think it doesn't matter it's
not a big deal I'll deal with it if I
ever have a problem guys it is so
inexpensive you so don't have to think
about it you click it you're good to go
do it I'm you will regret it if you
don't you have got to get expressvpn
visit my special link right now
expressvpn comm slash michael mi CH AE l
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free protect your internet today
with the VPN that I trust to keep my
data safe expressvpn dot-com / michael
mi CH AE l to get started what a great
decade
what a great decade this has been before
we get into why I want to issue one
slight correction but it
important it actually tells us a little
bit about what we're talking about today
you remember during the impeachment vote
last week there were all sorts of
speeches that were being given one of
which was the most powerful oration in
recent American history that was the
speech in which a congressman stood up
and said for the remainder of my time
I'm going to list all of the high crimes
and misdemeanors that President Trump
has committed I'm going to begin now and
then he was silent for a full minute and
then he relinquished his time it was a
beautiful powerful oration I mean
obviously was inspired by some seriously
dense political philosophy work I miss
identified who that congressman was and
I'm very sorry about that because it was
such a great speech so just to correct
the record that congressman who I
identified as bill Johnson was actually
Russ Bulger Congressman Fulcher my
apologies and my admiration sir you've
got them both the decade is coming to a
close the defining feature of this
decade in politics is the rise of the
right that's it
now I know what you're thinking you're
thinking we've had so many setbacks
that's true but in terms of the actual
popular politics political opinions it's
the rise of the right remember 2008
Barack Obama gets elected 2009 you get
the Affordable Care Act you get
Obamacare then you enter this new decade
2010 and 2010 begins with the rise of
the Tea Party 2010 rise of the Tea Party
they take over the House of
Representatives they're able to stymie
the rest of the Obama administration's
plans then over the course of the next
six years we win 1000 seats across the
country at the local state and federal
level a thousand seats Barack Obama
destroys the Democratic Party even
though Obama gets re-elected in 2012
virtually every other election all the
rest of the political momentum goes to
the right and then the decade ends with
the election of President Trump and the
first three years of the Trump
administration which approved wildly
popular on the economy just if you look
at his approval rating and even now from
the beginning of the impeachment process
to the
and president Trump's approval numbers
have gone up and now the majority of
Americans depending on which poll you
look at but multiple polls the majority
of Americans oppose impeachment and
removal even among Democrats the number
of people who support impeachment and
removal has dropped from 90% to
seventy-seven percent over the course of
the impeachment proceedings and that's
that's according to the CNN so take it
with a grain of salt but if anyone if
CNN we're gonna skew either way it would
skew to the left why does the decade not
feel like we've been winning the reason
is we've lost some major battles we've
lost huge amounts of cultural ground we
lost on the redefinition of marriage we
lost on the redefinition of sex itself
men are women and women are men all that
sort of stuff we've lost a lot and
Russell Kirk the great conservative
philosopher he actually says that
conservatism is about loss the chief
sentiment of conservatism is the feeling
of loss because you're trying to
conserve things and keep them going into
the future
and so you keenly feel all his losses so
sure we feel those losses but think
about what those losses look like they
weren't popular losses they weren't
losses even in elections they were
losses at the judicial level in all of
these cases the redefinition of marriage
increasingly the redefinition of sex now
someone just got sixteen years in the
clink for burning a gay pride flag all
those things were caused by a robed
lawyer overstepping his bounds otherwise
we're doing great if you look at the
direction of political support in the
country it all favors the right and we
just got some more good news on this
front because if the judiciary is the
main problem we've now learned president
Trump and cocaine Mitch have officially
confirmed 187 federal judges this is
Mitch McConnell's legacy and it's the
most important thing the president Trump
has done in all three years
well he's distracting with the tweets
well he's being impeached well he's
talking about Mika Brzezinski phase
while he's doing all this stuff in his
left hand look what he's doing with his
right he's getting all of these judges
through those judges have lifetime
appointments he and McConnell are
seriously outpacing Barack Obama now
there's a new report out
in for Circuit Court judges is a Trump
appointee so when Trump took office nine
of the country's thirteen circuit courts
had a majority of democratic judges now
seven of those thirteen courts have
Republican majorities and Trump is just
getting started if he assuming he gets
reelected right now things are looking
pretty good we'll get to the democratic
debate in a little bit to show you how
good it's looking if Trump gets a second
term he's going to uh turn form the
courts and the courts have been the sore
spot the courts have been the only rub
for the last ten years of conservative
politics Trump has now had 50 circuit
court judges confirmed it just to put
that in perspective at this point in his
presidency Barack Obama had only
confirmed 25 Circuit Court judges so at
the circuit level Trump is doubling what
Obama did and it's huge because the
judges are where we've lost the hardest
even Obama care
don't forget Obama care right Obama care
very very unpopular you had a Republican
in Massachusetts win Ted Kennedy's
Senate seat just so that he could be the
vote against Obamacare but they wheel
and deal and they finally push it
through despite massive popular popular
opposition to Obamacare it's obviously
unconstitutional it's the federal
government forcing people to buy a
private service and never had that in
our nation's history they get it through
John Roberts completely caves and we get
that Supreme Court decision then we get
obergefell that was the case that
redefined marriage because Justice
Kennedy is basically a romantic poet on
the bench and he decided that actually
unbeknownst to all of us the
Constitution defines marriage not as it
had always been defined of thread all of
history or as it was understood at the
time but as the monogamous union of
couples regardless of their their sex
then we have increasingly the
redefinition of sex on the basis of
gender ideology increasingly of the
erosion of our liberties especially our
political liberties all at the judiciary
and now Trump isn't getting enough
credit for these judges right because
people aren't paying attention they
don't realize where
the losses are we just feel the losses
but if you change the judiciary all that
goes away and it's so important I'll
show you how important it is right now
there's a story coming out of central
Iowa a man has been sentenced to a
little under 16 years in prison for
burning an LGBT rainbow flag
his name is Adolfo Martinez his 30 year
olds he's from Ames Iowa he was just
sentenced over 15 years for a hate crime
specifically was arson and theft yet
because this guy Martinez saw a gay
pride flag on a church and he went over
there he stole the flag he then lit it
on fire because he opposes homosexuality
all of his sentences are gonna be served
consecutively it is as large a sentence
as he could possibly get what it was a
crime here obviously stealing is a crime
so he should be punished for that arson
is a crime setting it on fire he should
be punished for that but you don't get
16 years in the clink for stealing a
flag you don't get 16 years in prison
for lighting a match where you shouldn't
lie to match you get 16 years in prison
you get sentenced to the absolute
maximum allowed by law for a hate crime
and what is the hate crime
burning the LGBT flag I mean how insane
is this situation where in the United
States if you burn an American flag the
symbol of our entire country that's
totally fine that's you would be
celebrated by the left and by civil
libertarians for expressing your free
speech rights we now know I mean even
Antonin Scalia would say this that there
is a protected speech right in burning
an American flag and yet you burn a gay
pride flag you go to jail for 16 years
what would the founders think about that
the the defense of this sentence is that
he stole the flag you don't get 16 years
in prison for stealing flags and the
people who were cheering this on by the
way are the ones who say we need to
empty the jails and stop putting people
in jail for minor crimes like petty
theft or drug crimes or right they're
the one thing we need to get people out
of your prison
form sentencing reform and they're
cheering this on that a man gets 16
years in prison for burning a gay pride
flag this highlights an important topic
that we've been talking about for months
and if we want the next decade to be
another conservative decade we're gonna
have to get this through our heads there
are some well-meaning people on the
right who never want the government to
advance our cultural priorities because
they think that secular liberalism is
completely neutral so what I mean by
that is you have people even on the
right who say we can never have the
government push our idea of the good we
can never have the government say
encourage public prayer we can never
have the government encouraged the
mention of God like all of our founding
fathers did like it is on our currency
we can never have them push social
conservatism because that would be wrong
that's not we're no different than than
how the left is when they push their
radicalism from the government and
therefore what we really need is to step
back and let the government just be a
neutral playing field and we'll fight
all of our battles in the culture as
though there were some neat distinction
between politics and culture now the
premise here I guess is you don't want
any blurring of the line between church
and state that's the best way to
maintain our liberties but that is BS
because we do have an established Church
in America we have the Church of leftism
we have a secular liturgical calendar
okay we have Black History Month which
is not actually about Black History it's
about a leftist version of Black History
we have Women's History Month it's not
about women's history it's about a
secular leftist version of women's
history we have Pride Month now which
isn't even about celebrating homosexuals
anymore now there's another month for
that which is October Pride Month in
June is actually just about celebrating
pride all sorts of pride fat pride
skinny pride all kinds of pride that is
a secular liturgical calendar just like
any Church as a liturgical calendar okay
and we have secular saints we have
secular sins I argued a few months ago
on this show I argued in favor of a
constitutional amendment to prohibit
flag-burning
not because I think it's the most
important
thing in the world not I wouldn't stake
it as my number one priority but I think
it would be helpful if we if we came
together as a country and said we're not
gonna let you burn the flag because the
flag is the symbol of the country my
reasoning here is if the flag is the
symbol of the country then we should
raise it up a little bit
we should sanctify it a little bit we
should if we should have something
shared together that is sacred because
we're going to do that right the
Declaration of Independence Declaration
of Independence declares that we have
natural rights that we are endowed with
by our Creator that's a religious
statement ok the state always has a
relation to the spiritual to the
religious this has been true in every
government for in the history of the
world and so the question is what kind
of relationship are we going to have we
had a very very delicate balance in
America we have we're the most
religiously tolerant country that has
ever existed on earth at least until
recently because the kind of
Christianity that that formed the basis
of the American religion was much much
more tolerant than leftism and
liberalism which is the current Church
of America all right and just
just these two flags sum it up we are
going to sanctify something in this
country so either we're gonna sanctify a
symbol of our nation the u.s. flag or
we're going to sanctify some other
symbol we're gonna come together and
raise up the Stars and Stripes or we're
gonna raise up the rainbow flag but one
of those is going to become the
cherished symbol activists judges want
it to be the latter I think the American
people want it to be the former and I
think that distinction is the key to
understanding the last decade in
politics and I think that is why we are
winning
I think Obamacare was an overreach I
think obergefell was an overreach I
think transgenderism is a major major
overreach
I mean I've long said I think this
transgender movement is the straw that
broke the camel's back of political
correctness of marching leftism
this movement isn't only happening in
the United States there is a popular
conservative movement that is way bigger
than the United States you see it in
Europe you see it in the United Kingdom
you even see it among liberals in the
United Kingdom unbelievable story out
today from the author JK Rowling who
wrote the Harry Potter books JK Rowling
is a major live ok she's a huge liberal
she's always tweeting about feminist
things every other day she's making some
old Harry Potter character gay like
she'll go back and rewrite it from 15
years ago and all of a sudden Dumbledore
is gay they're gonna make the owl gay
pretty soon she's always adding these
kind of PC politics but she wouldn't go
all the way with the left so there's a
controversy now that JK Rowling is in
surrounding the case of Maya for stater
who is a British scholar who lost her
job because she said that men cannot
magically become women simply by wishing
it so this is a British academic who got
fired from her academic job for stating
a scientific fact a fact of nature and
JK Rowling has come out in defense of
this woman
JK Rowling tweeted out quote dress
however you please call yourself
whatever you like sleep with any
consenting adult who will have you yikes
sort of an underhanded complement live
your best life in peace and security but
force women out of their jobs for
stating that sex is real hashtag I stand
with Maya hashtag this is not a drill
right now in this statement JK Rowling
is summing up the kind of liberal
worldview dress whatever you want like
whatever you want call yourself whatever
you want sleep with everybody free love
it's fine but don't coerce women into
lying
don't force women out of their jobs for
stating facts the important lesson here
for the whole culture not just
conservatives conservatives understood
this lesson decades ago but for the
center for the center left for the
center right for the independence the
important lesson here is when it comes
to leftism it's never enough it's never
enough they
get you eventually they will turn on you
eventually you can never be extreme
enough in a way in a sort of
glass-half-full way our losses at the
judicial level this decade which have
been significant or almost helpful look
at look at the 1970s Roe vs. Wade the
possibly the worst Supreme Court
decision in American history completely
galvanized the pro-life movement at the
time of Roe vs. Wade all of the public
opinion in this country was moving in
the direction of supporting abortion
after Roe versus Wade it completely
turned back now we've basically never
been more pro-life than we are today and
I think we're seeing this on other
cultural issues I think we're seeing it
on what it means to be human I think
we're seeing it on what it means to be a
man I think we're seeing it on what it
means to be a conservative I mean that's
the debate that's been happening now and
in the midst of all this they're trying
to impeach the president they're trying
to stave all the the judicial
bloodletting basically because even even
the Ninth Circuit which is a incredibly
liberal court historically even that now
is becoming a conservative Court thanks
to the Trump appointees in the midst of
all of this the Democrats meet to debate
what they stand for what their policy
priorities are how they're going to turn
this thing around they have no answer
they have no answer we will go through
some of the highlights I mean this
debate was so dumb you really only need
to see five or six of them but there are
a few moments here that show you that
the Democrats are really really in
trouble
and they're they're basically looking at
looking around the country after the
kind of destruction and desolation of
the Obama administration that took this
historic liberal victory and then just
completely squandered him they're
looking around and they're saying how do
we rebuild they don't have an answer the
first line of the night that made me
think that the left just has no serious
vision for 2020 came from Elizabeth
Warren Elizabeth Warren's had all the
big momentum going in for the past two
months now right Elizabeth Warren came
out of nowhere
she was pretty much dead in the water
because she's lying
because she published that DNA results
that show that she's one thousand one
one thousand twenty-fourth Native
American maybe she lied about her record
at Harvard she lied about her ancestry
she lied about sending her child to
public schools I mean she's just a weak
candidate she's a damaged candidate she
has that awful voice and yet she was
rising in the polls because Biden was
collapsing because Bernie Sanders had a
heart attack because there was nobody
else well she wasn't rising out of her
own talent she was rising because the
field was so so weak so Elizabeth Warren
puts out her economic plans she
basically wants to promise everybody the
world and then pretend that their taxes
aren't going to go up to their credit
the moderators of this debate came out
and said senator Warren how do you
respond to economists who say your plan
isn't going to work this is Liz Warren's
answer this is the best she could do how
do you answer top economists who say
taxes of this magnitude would stifle
growth and investment oh they're just
wrong that's it that's the best you got
this reminds me of this moment in 2012
when Herman Cain you know the former CEO
of Godfather's Pizza Herman Cain comes
out and he's got his $9.99 tax plan and
the 999 plan is going to totally
revolutionize the economy we're gonna
have a ton of growth and a moderator one
of these debates said excuse me mr. Cain
what do you say to the economists who
who analyzed your plan they say it
doesn't work like what do you make of
that analysis and Herman Cain issued I
think it's my favorite quote from any
presidential debate ever he said well
the problem with their analysis is that
it is incorrect I thought that sums it
up that's perfect a problem with their
analysis is that it is incorrect
Liz Warren is using the same line here
and guess what it didn't work out very
well for Herman Cain I don't think it's
gonna work out well for Elizabeth Warren
you need a more serious answer than that
you can only channel populist rage so
long and Liz Warren's not even good at
doing it because she's actually just a a
lying Harvard professor establishment
arian fraud so she doesn't even get the
kind of
the rail of popular support she's more
like a scolding librarian it's not gonna
work well for her she needs to come up
with an answer to these economists who
were pointing out that her plan is gonna
completely destroy growth I mean just if
you just look at the health care plan
alone it's 52 trillion dollars total
over ten years if you took all the
wealth away from every single
billionaire in the entire country all
621 of them if you stole that shirt off
their backs you would pay for basically
three fifths of one year of that plan
and then what obviously people's taxes
are gonna go up businesses are gonna get
crushed growth is going to stop you're
the economy very likely would recess you
got to answer that if she's not gonna
answer that she's not really going
anywhere the biggest moment of the
debate involves Elizabeth Warren too
because she she tried to lob an attack
on Pete Buddha judge all of a sudden
when people are realizing how weak Liz
Warren is especially after she released
that disastrous health care plan now
some of the momentum is going to mayor
Pete Moo to judge and so Warren wants to
cut him off before he gets too big and
keep the momentum on her so the big
moment of the debate is Warren goes
after Buddha judge and it doesn't go the
way Liz Warren once she loves this
attack she said Pete Buddha jej had a
big high dollar fundraiser in a wine
cave and that's not the kind of
representation America needs Buddha
judge completely flips it around and
uses the attack against her there just
recently had a fundraiser that was held
in a wine cave full of crystals and
served $900 a bottle wine um think about
who comes to that he had promised that
every fundraiser he would do would be
open door but this one was closed door
we made the decision many years ago that
rich people in smoke-filled rooms would
not pick the next president of the
United States billionaires and wine
caves should not pick the next president
of the United States mr. mayor your
response you know according to Forest
Magazine
I am the literally the only person on
this stage who's not a millionaire or a
billionaire so if
this is the problem with issuing purity
tests you cannot yourself pass that is a
great line this is the problem with
issuing purity tests that you cannot
yourself passed he didn't get in the mud
he didn't start calling her crooked
Elizabeth he didn't start really getting
personal
because he doesn't have the gravitas for
that he's a young kid he looks like
Alfred E Neuman
he's a mayor of a small town he's got a
play earnest he can't come from it from
a position that's too aggressive but he
points out that she's a total hypocrite
on this she's she's worth a lot more
money than he is then it came out by the
way that last year at a fundraiser last
year Elizabeth Warren also hosted a big
dollar wine fundraiser and actually the
gift if you if you gave over a thousand
dollars to her was a souvenir wine
bottle so the attack is just completely
disingenuous that's that's the hallmark
of Liz Warren's political career though
is this shamelessness and this cynicism
she'll be whatever she she wants or
whatever her audience wants her to be P
Budaj edge coming out and attacking her
for it now is Budaj edge the strong
candidate I don't think so
Pete Budaj edge has basically zero black
support the I have a number of friends
and family members who like Pete Budaj
into a person they are all upper-middle
class whites who live in urban areas
that is not how you cobble together a
winning political coalition especially
when multiple polls are showing the
president Trump is making huge inroads
among black voters and among Hispanic
voters
the Emerson poll put Trump's black
support a thirty four point five percent
now call that an outlier poll fine other
other polls are showing 30% high 20s
among Hispanic voters you're looking at
thirty thirty eight percent if Trump
gets even fifteen or twenty percent of
the black vote significantly lower than
the polls are showing then the Democrats
are done so they need a candidate who
can appeal to those voters they form the
basis of their they form the foundation
of their base so now Budaj edge is on
shaky ground well what about Bernie
okay Bernie's been around a long time
he's been around at least what three
four hundred years at this point maybe
Bernie will be the guy who can can
finally
push this race into the mainstream
except he can't Bernie Sanders was asked
a question on race he's got the same
race problem Buddha judge does he's just
has very very low black support and they
said how do you respond to this question
on race and Bernie Sanders tried to turn
it to global warming listen to how
pathetic this is what I wanted to get
back to issue of climate change for a
moment because I do believe this is the
existential issue senator with all
respect this question is about race can
you answer the question as it
people of color in fact are going to be
D people suffering most if we do not
deal with climate change
ah what a horrible response Bernie they
say that a fanatic is someone who can't
change his mind and won't change the
subject that is what the left has become
on their religion to jour
environmentalism the answer to
everything is the green New Deal its
global warming it's the world is about
to end it all comes together in the
totalizing plan of the of the green new
deal which includes socialist health
care job guarantee program reparations
for slavery massive redistribution of
wealth that's their answer for
everything but if you if you want to
appeal to the American people first of
all you can't pick this one very
esoteric issue that most people don't
even think is happening or is really
threatening to destroy our civilization
but to if they ask you about something
else you got to know how to change the
subject
and say hey Bernie you have this big
weakness when it comes to race how you
going to address that global warming
Bernie respectfully we're not talking
about that now we're talking about race
what do you say about race global
warming is important to race no that's
not gonna go anywhere so Bernie it's not
looking great now some people are saying
we might have the Amy Klobuchar moment
Amy Klobuchar is a Midwestern she's
moderate she's a woman she checks a lot
of boxes maybe Amy Klobuchar is gonna
break through I think that's probably
unlikely we'll hear from her in a second
and then we'll get to the kingpin
himself Joe Biden and look at how the
the Biden campaign is heading into 2020
because he made a big decision at this
debate and nobody is reporting on it but
it actually is the most significant
strategic change that the Biden campaign
has made to date we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to Christianity today
endorsing the removal of President Trump
from office and we will get to some
myths about Christmas there's one in
particular that drives me crazy we will
clear that up before we head into
Christmas and New Year's but first my
friends listen up I am about to save you
time and money this Christmas season
I am doing that for you out of the
goodness of my heart and also look it'll
help the company it'll help you the
perfect gift for your loved ones it's a
daily wired gift membership from now
until January 1st all insider plus gift
memberships will be 25% off that means
that your loved one will get all the
fantastic perks plus the leftist tiers
tumbler and you will get the savings
this is what I love it's a win-win
because the person you give it to gets a
nice membership we get your wonderful
wonderful support and you get to save a
little bit of money win-win-win
go to daily wire.com slash gift to get
25 percent off that is 25 percent off
all insider plus gift memberships of
this holiday season give them a gift
that they will thank you for all year
long especially going into 2020 an
election season you're gonna need that
tumbler or you're gonna drown go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back with
a lot more
so Warren looking weak Budaj edge
he's got some momentum but he looks like
he's got some some pretty fatal
weaknesses on his campaign specifically
his appeal to minority voters Bernie
Sanders pretty much the same thing also
Bernie especially this debate just came
off as a screaming old man so he would
be very very old he'd be what 80 - by
the end of his first term it's just not
looking great so how about club you char
is this the club you charm moment it
could be she has the policy preferences
that would appeal to a vast majority of
people she's got the sex that would
appeal to Democrats because she's not a
straight white man she's a straight
white woman but you know at least that
gives you one intersectional box she's
from the Midwest she's from an important
area and yet she's just so stiff and
unappealing here if I had to sum up the
Amy Klobuchar campaign in 30 seconds it
would be these clips from the debate of
Amy Klobuchar trying to make a joke
trying to seem human and just falling
flat women in our government when I was
on Trevor Noah's show once I explained
how in the history of the Senate there
was something like 2,000 men and only 50
women in the whole history and he said
if a nightclub had numbers that bad they
would shut it down and I have never even
been to a wine cave I've been to the
wind cave in South Dakota which I
suggest you go to what I've that's the
pun you're gonna have never been to a
wine cave I've been to the wind cave
which is a place you've never heard of
in a place you've never visited which
has nothing to do with what we're
talking about is that how you joke is
that is that a joke like the that's that
meme of like the looking at the
butterfly is this what a joke is that's
not a joke the first time she tries to
make a joke in the debate she doesn't
even make the joke herself she just
quotes an actual comedian telling a joke
in her presence said I was on Trevor
Noah's show and he said that if the
ratio of men and women in the history of
the Senate were the
ratio of men and women in a bar the bar
would close beep-boop beep-boop is that
a joke ha ha ha no it's and I know this
seems like a trivial point I know this
seems minor it's like well not everyone
is Don Rickles but first of all when
you're running against President Trump
you kind of need Don Rickles like you a
the guy is so entertaining that you
really do need to have a lot of
personality generally speaking in the
history of the u.s. presidency the
bigger personality wins the more
memorable personality wins but also what
it shows with Klobuchar is she just
doesn't have her finger on the pulse of
people she doesn't know how to relate to
people she doesn't know what makes
people tick she doesn't know what makes
people laugh if you can make people
laugh there's a good chance you
understand what motivates them you
understand their psychology and their
nature a little bit better than the
person who just can't relate so right
you're gonna hear a lot of talk over the
next few weeks of maybe this is club
your chores moment maybe she's gonna
take off yeah maybe she will I wouldn't
bet on it then you get to Joe Biden he's
the last one he's still the big dog at
this point is probably the nominee Joe
Biden his past his sell-by date hears
there's actually one moment I want to
give a little bit of credit to Joe Biden
because there's this hilarious exchange
that shows the difference between the
kind of democratic leftist insurgency
and old Joe who's been around for 50
years and it comes when he's asked a
question about Afghanistan and the
moderator asked the question and she
decides to pronounce it Afghanistan and
Biden is so old both in his kind of
worldview and just in his body that he
doesn't even know what she's talking
about any Korean what what country
you're talking about Afghanistan here it
is president let's turn now to
Afghanistan confidential documents
published last week by The Washington
Post revealed that for years senior US
officials misled the public about the
war in Afghanistan that's vice president
one did you know Afghanistan yes sir yes
yes sir
I actually want to I want to complement
Biden because he is Tran
Lading for the American people from
liberal into American the left always
does this the left always pronounces
foreign words as if they themselves
don't speak English and the of Kony's
done is the new one but they've done it
for a long time you heard Barack Obama
do it with Pakistan so he'd be talking
like a completely normal person
obviously Barack Obama is a very
eloquent speaker and then he'd get to
the word Pakistan and he would say and
you know we we've got a lot of our
friends and buckey's done say why do you
pronouncing it like that or the left
always does it with with Muslim no
instead of saying Muslim which is how
you pronounce that word in English
they'll say Muslim we like it well you
know and because of the Muslims in
Pakistan it's like why are you shift why
is your accent shifting now they're
doing it with Afghanistan and she makes
a point of pronouncing it that way like
multiple times then Joe Biden's there
you can barely hear anything is what
what sorry what's that that's the new
liberal way to pronounce Afghanistan yes
mr. vice president of commute son I I
don't do this when I speak if I go to an
Italian restaurant look I am Italian all
right I speak Italian I've spent a lot
of time in Italy if I go to an Italian
restaurant in America where you go down
in New York somewhere I don't sit down
and say oh hey waiter yeah I'll get a
glass of red wine and some of those
breadsticks that'd be great and then
I'll have a bowl of you spaghetti you
know how to bow not up but if I though
at him yeah that's you got it they want
the red wine and the garlicky
breadsticks those are really good and
yeah then I'll have spaghetti alla
Carbonara God Seco European II know you
don't do that you say I y'all this
spaghetti carbonara Thanks
because you're in America and you're
speaking English and that's what you do
but the left they don't do like I don't
what do you think doing it all these
sort of Mexican restaurants and then
especially when they're talking about
the Middle East so I like the Biden was
just having none of it he's just so
tired and he's just so sick of this
campaign and it's like the most joyless
slog that I've seen to the presidency
since Hillary Clinton and that didn't
work out well for her but the reason I
bring up the Afghanistan moment is not
just to highlight this kind of funny
pronunciation thing it's because Joe
Biden at this debate
made a pretty major strategic shift he's
now going after Obama he's now
distancing himself from Obama he's doing
it very subtly but he's doing it
nonetheless Joe Biden until this moment
has had one major campaign message and
that message is I was friends with
Barack Obama
that's the message my good friend Barack
Obama I served with Barack Obama I did
what Obama wanted me to do the closer I
can appear to be to Barack Obama the
better chance I have of getting the
nomination now he's not doing that he
was after bad asked about Afghanistan
surging troops in Afghanistan was Barack
Obama's signature foreign policy
contribution for the 2008 campaign and
what Joe Biden answers on Afghanistan is
I opposed it it was a dumb idea I don't
think we should have done it here's Jeff
president what did you know about the
state of the war and do you believe that
you were honest with the American people
about it reason I can speak to this it's
well known many of you followed it my
view on Afghanistan I was sent by the
president before we got sworn into
Afghanistan to come back with a report I
said there was no comprehensive policy
available and then I got in a big fight
for a long time with the Pentagon
because I strongly opposed the
nation-building notion we said about
rebuilding that country as a whole
nation is beyond our capacity look it's
a it's an ambitious move I mean he's
basically saying look Barack you keep
attacking me implicitly and so I'm gonna
stop pretending to be good friends with
you I mean it's been one indignity after
another from Obama to Biden Obama would
not endorse him right out the bat that
was pretty rough for Joe Biden then
Barack Obama just came out and he said
old man caused all the problems in the
world and they shouldn't run for office
anymore and only women should be in
office I mean that's a pretty market
attack it at Joe Biden and now Joe Biden
says I'm not gonna take it anymore
I'm gonna distance myself so will that
pay off the trouble with this strategy
well it might give Biden a little bit
more dignity is that Joe Biden has
nothing other than his
relationship with Barack Obama he's been
a doofus his entire political career and
I mean that not just insultingly
to throw it a mean term around I mean it
very technically he's just been kind of
nothing he's a glad-handing politician
who stands for nothing
the one legislative accomplishment he's
got the crime bill in 1994 which was a
good law he has to distance himself from
in this primary so what's he got why
would you elect him he dropped out in
1988 because he was a liar because he
was a plagiarist he lost in 2008 because
he didn't stand for anything why is he
going to be better now that he's 77
years old it's not now gonna worry I
mean just to drive this point home one
point in the debate Joe Biden thought
that the way that I can really jump out
here is by doing my best impression of a
stuttering child I have a call list of
somewhere between twenty and a hundred
people that we call at least every week
or every month to tell them I'm here
I've given them my private phone number
they keep in touch with me a little kid
who says III III III I can't I can't
talk what do I do
I have scores of these young women and
men if you have trouble talking if you
have trouble getting coherent thoughts
out of your head through words Joe Biden
probably not the best guy to ask for
advice but it just shows you people are
attacking Biden because they say that
he's mocking a child I don't think he's
mocking a child I don't think this
experience actually ever even happened I
don't think a stuttering child came up
to him and spoke that way and he had
this really heartfelt moment with him I
just think Joe Biden has no regard for
the truth the only tool he has at his
disposal is this saccharine sentimental
trying to paint these Rosie's
sympathetic pictures and that falls flat
and it falls awkward and he doesn't
doesn't stand for much so that's the
state of the current Democratic
presidential candidates heading into
2020 it's been a rough decade for them
and it looks like the next one might be
two on our front I before we go I want
to make a couple points about Christmas
first of all Christianity today which is
a major evangelical magazine that was
founded by Billy Graham has come out and
supported Trump's removal from office
the headline of the editorial says Trump
should be removed
office it's time to say what we said 20
years ago when a president's character
was revealed for what it was they the
piece goes on to the many evangelicals
who continue to support mr. Trump in
spite of his blackened moral record we
might say this remember who you are and
whom you serve consider how your
justification of mr. Trump influences
your witness to your Lord and Savior can
we say with a straight face that
abortion is a great evil that cannot be
tolerated and with the same straight
face say that the bent and broken
character of our nascent Nations leader
doesn't really matter in the end yes we
can say that we can say that it is more
important to reduce abortion and to set
up a judicial culture that will likely
curb abortion then it is to worry about
Trump sleeping with stormy Daniels 15
years ago 15 years ago it's more
important get your priorities in order
what a stupid stupid editorial the
editor in chief mark galley of
Christianity today he's stepping down
he'd already renowned announced his
retirement but it is kind of ironic that
the only one being removed from office
as a result of this is the
editor-in-chief of Christianity today
Franklin Graham whose father Billy
started the magazine he absolutely
eviscerated them if Franklin Graham said
Christianity today released an editorial
stating the president Trump should be
removed from office and they invoked my
father is a name I supposed to try to
bring into judoma see to their
statements so I feel it's important for
me to respond
yes my father Billy Graham found in
Christianity today but no he would not
agree with their opinion peace he
believes that Donald J Trump was the man
for this hour in history for our nation
and that's kind of the point here it
shows your big divide you know the
people who run this magazine the
editorial board who go to nice cocktail
parties they think we have to remove
Trump from office because why because he
sends mean tweets or something obviously
he didn't he didn't commit an
impeachable offense the Democrats don't
even really pretend that he did that's
why they dropped the bribery charge the
readership of Christianity's day furious
the son Franklin Graham of the founder
of Christianity today furious is they
have their priorities in order and we
should too as we look back on the decade
it's been a good decade for
conservatives we were on the brink
in 2009 major major healthcare planned
Barack Obama transformative radical
president we were on the brink and
starting in 2010 we came back the Tea
Party was elected they immediately
thwarted Barack Obama's biggest
initiatives we supported Hillary Clinton
in 2016 the courts Delta sand blows but
now we are reshaping the courts and
speaking of that speaking of winning I
want to point out in the spirit of the
season we're even winning the war on
Christmas we are winning the war on
Christmas is back
people aren't renaming Christmas trees
holiday trees anymore more people are
saying Merry Christmas we're not
pretending that Kwanzaa is a thing
anymore Kwanzaa is just a made-up
holiday from a Cal State Los Angeles
professor that has no historical or
religious significance it's just
socialism with a little race hustling
mixed in and it was invented by a guy
who repeatedly tortured and sexually
assaulted women it's just nothing nobody
celebrates it it's Christmas it's
Christmas season we're even winning that
before we go I want to clear up a little
myth about Christmas just a little a
little nugget of Christmas knowledge you
can spread around your family's
festivities there is a myth that has
gone around for a long time now that
Christmas isn't really Christmas that
that Christmas being celebrated on
December 25th is really just a sort of
pagan invention and it was a way for the
early Christians to try to win over the
hearts and minds of the pagans that that
were in ancient Rome and outside of
ancient Rome and there's just no
evidence for that whatsoever so there
are three pagan holidays that are also
around this time Saturnalia the the
festival of Saturn Sol Invictus the
Unconquered Sun and Mithras and they're
saying basically that the early
Christians just chose randomly December
25th not because Jesus was born that day
or because they earnestly believed he
was born that day but to appeal to the
pagans Saturnalia is the only one of
those that was celebrated a full two
centuries or more before Christmas so
that's around the same time that is a
bit of a coincidence there are no
contemporary sources linking the two
holidays you would think if the if the
early Christians
who wrote a lot and they wrote a lot to
each other were really conscious about
trying to pick this day to appeal to the
pagans you think one of them would have
written it down somewhere don't you one
of it want to mentioned in the many
historical records we don't have any
record of that in terms of Sol Invictus
and Mithras it's even less tenable the
Sol Invictus the Unconquered Sun was not
even celebrated annually and it came
about after Christmas so you had
Christmas celebrations on or around
December 25th
before you had widespread Sol Invictus
celebrations if anything it was a pagan
response to Christmas the likeliest
reason for the celebration of Christmas
on December 25th actually just comes
from Christianity itself and from an
ancient view of divinity so the the best
theory we have we don't know for certain
there are a few other theories but the
the most likely one we have which
serious academics believe is the
strongest scholarly explanation for it
is that at that time at the time of the
early Christians it was believed that
divine life would have to begin and end
on the same day that it was right that
it was seemly for the life to begin and
end in a perfect year so Christ as 33
years old when he dies that's what it's
got to be so since the 2nd century isn't
the time of Tertullian March 25th was
believed to be the date of the
crucifixion the crucifixion and the
death of Christ that would mean that it
would also have to be the date of the
Annunciation or the conception of Christ
when the angel comes down and tells Mary
you will be taken with the Holy Spirit
and conceived a child now if you're
conceived on March 25th nine months
later you get the birth of December 25th
that is a belief that we have had for
over 1,800 years so when people tell you
that Christmas being celebrated on
December 25th was just some invention of
the Middle Ages or something like that
or or they'll say at the same time even
though it's contradictory that it was
just a way to appeal to pagans or
something that really isn't the case
what
Christ born on December 25th some of the
early church fathers suggested other
dates you know there were there was some
debate about this but for virtually the
entire history of Christianity the
church has decided that it was on or
around December 25th
that's good enough for me and without
any other evidence to the contrary that
seems about right to me that it that
that was really the date that Christ was
born or might as well be the date that
Christ was born then it really happened
and that's such an important aspect of
this season is that it really happened
it tells us something real and as we
head into 2020 we're going to be looking
at real things not the kind of an
imaginary the imaginary losses the
imaginary hopelessness of the
conservative cause the imaginary fake
news that is constantly being reported
we're looking at real things and I think
the reality bodes very well for us Merry
Christmas
I'll see you in the new year I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer
Mathis clever and Robert Stirling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director hovel Woodhouse key
editor and associate producer Danny
D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Jeshua alvera production
assistant McKenna Waters the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you